Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to
Diego from California.
Speaker 2: Hello. Hello. What's going on? I had a
question about what do you think about the
growth of people being interested in socialism
or any sort of radical kind of
socialist ideologies in America?
Speaker 1: I don't know. I mean, I think it's not
surprising that when a system is failing that it
creates a window of opportunity of getting people
to jump on board with really different systems.
So like, for example, I would agree with the
Socialists that our form of capitalism has failed
so many people. But for me, the solution is well
regulated capitalism called social democracy
in the northern European model. But I understand
how if someone is just getting introduced to
some of this stuff, whatever it seems the most
different from what we have, we'll have a certain
amount of appeal. So I guess I'd say it's not it's
not super surprising that that's what's going on.
Speaker 2: Yeah. With the Nordic model,
what I found interesting is the role
of like more radical socialist elements in those
countries that helped push for some of the social
democratic things like rent controls and other
government programs. Do you think that could
be achieved here or what's your opinion on that?
Speaker 1: Generally, could which part be achieved
here? Just having rent controls, I guess.
Speaker 2: Do you think a
revolutionary radical socialist element in the
country could serve to bolster social democracy
in America like it did at times in Scandinavia?
Speaker 1: I think so. And I've said before I had
an interview with a streamer who goes by the
name Varsh. Some people say Vash, some people
say the oche. And while he is a socialist and I
am not, we were in agreement that right now the
Social Democrats and the Socialists should really
be pushing for very similar socially Democratic
policies, because if there is to be socialism,
it will quite likely go through social democracy.
Now, there's a different revolutionary perspective
which says, no, no, no, no, no, there's no need to
go through social democracy. You just got to crush
capitalism and then put in socialism. I just even
though I'm not a socialist, to me, the most likely
path to socialism is through social democracy. So,
yeah, I agree that right now Social Democrats
and actual socialists could very much be united
on getting to social Democratic policy if and when
we get the US to be more like that. At that point,
the Social Democrats and the Socialists
can fight it out for whether we keep going.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I generally agree at this current
point with both of the parties being pretty like
the Democrat and Republican parties being pretty
like pretty rough when it comes to capitalism and
they're kind of just unbridled support for it. So
it does seem like anyone left of that is kind of a
it's kind of left out in the dust, you know?
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, I don't. There's a lot
of people that are just outside of that two
party paradigm. And it's not surprising that
when something else comes along that's appeal to
them, that they would gravitate towards it. No,
no shock at all.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm. Well,
thanks for answer my question. That's cool.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. All right, sir. Diego,
very much appreciate the call, sir. Sure.